Hey, Dan, we finished the settings.
Do you want to check it out?
Oh, great.
Wait, what's with all
this stuff right here?
I'm glad you asked.
All this stuff will help me demonstrate
the power of implicit intents,
leveraging other apps
to get functionality
for your app for free.
For example, why would you
write a bar code scanning app
when you can just launch
an intent to do it for you.
(crunching glass)
Or a camera app,
when you can just launch
an intent to fire a photo.
(glass shatters)
And of course, it would make no sense
to write a phone app just to dial
a phone number.
- You would just call the intent.
- Wait, I need that.
In other words, don't reinvent the wheel.
Lazy programmers make fewer mistakes.
Now, let's go implement
an implicit intent.
Raydo?
Dan's being implicit again.